Ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di "Cucina Buttata"
Febbraio è il mese dell'amore, lo sappiamo tutti quanti,
fra quattro giorni sarà San Valentino
e voglio celebrare questa giornata
vestendomi di nero, a lutto
Scherzi a parte una delle cose
traumatiche di San Valentino è quella di
fare un regalo alla propria dolce metà.
Potrebbe non essere proprio quello che
il vostro partner desidera più di ogni
altra cosa e quindi ho pensato perché
non lo incartiamo in maniera intelligente?
Perché non facciamo una sorpresa allo stesso tempo
e quindi perché non
facciamo una torta con dentro un regalo
Ha senso no?
Voglio mettere un regalo in
una torta. Andava meglio? Ok
Ora siamo ancora più fighi. Secondo gli
studi all'interno del nostro diciamo lab creativo
abbiamo scoperto che le cose
che piacciono di più su internet sono
il cibo, i gattini, e le fighe. Ora non potevo
prendere un cucciolo di gattino anche
perché sarebbe stato comunque, secondo me spiacevole, nei confronti del povero animale
ma ho trovato un modo per
evitare di sporcarmi ogni volta i vestiti
sono stanco di doverli mettere in lavatrice ogni volta che finisco di girare
e allo stesso tempo portare qui una stra
fregna cosmica
Quindi partiamo subito col procedimento perché oggi oltre che imparare come infilare un regalo
all'interno di una torta, impareremo
anche come fare il pan di spagna al
microonde, perché io non ho tempo per
mettere roba in forno, sinceramente mi
devo sbrigare e tutto questo amore per
questa festività non ce l'ho
Per fare il pan di spagna avremo bisogno di farina, lievito per dolci, burro, uova, zucchero e due cucchiai d'acqua
Prendiamo una...un recipiente, che avevamo qui
e iniziamo con la farina. Ma è stato lavato
questo qui l'ultima volta nel 15/18?
Lo usavano i militari come elmetto anti
guerra?
225 grammi di farina che dobbiamo setacciare. No io non ho sistemato il setaccino cacchio!
Mi impressioni con quella parannanza (Chef Mario)
Si? Sai che me lo dicono un sacco di persone anche quando tolgo la parannanza
227. Del resto non è che ho imparato che in cucina bisogna essere precisi
Idem con lo  zucchero (Chef Mario )
Si si si un secondo
Mamma mia già sta iniziando a sporcare (Chef Rico)
Già stai iniziando a rompere i c******i eh?
Ma non si era rotto quel coso? (Chef Mario)
Si. Shakalacalacalacalacalacalacalacalaca
Puntate sempre alla mediocrità
Chi punta al successo verrà solo deluso. Che p***e setacciare
"Setacciare il liefito". Si vede l'impronta tedesca? Di Chef Wilhelm? Ops è caduto. Ops mi sono sporcato le mani
"Zapore". 225 grammi di burro. Comunque
quando fai i dolci te rendi conto di
quanta roba te magni. L'ignoranza è un bene.
Siate ignoranti
27 tolgo...va beh va bene
Andiamo al microonde. Ho sempre un po' di
problemi con questo microonde
Ah...trenta secondi...al microonde
Tiè! Anzi è un po sciolto. Morbido!
Aggiungiamo il burro
aggiungiamo 4 uova
Tra parentesi vorrei ringraziare "SugarDany89" perché stiamo prendendo la sua ricetta
Figuriamoci se l'ho pensata io
Questo lasciamolo da parte
Sicuramente uno è dell'idraulico (Chef Rico)
Uno è dell'albatros
Acqua
Ma può esse ti manca la vanillina ancora?(Chef Mario)
No perché ho il lievito vanigliato
Perché era per la ricetta (Chef Mario)
Eh abbiamo sbagliato. Va beh se ci tieni tanto ce la metto la vanillina
Chef Mario vuole la vanillina e noi mettiamo anche la vanillina...contento?
Ma lo zucchero io non ce l'ho messo. Lo zucchero andava messo prima, 225 grammi
Te l'avevo detto eh? (Chef Mario)
Come sei bravo!
Sapete che secondo me
dobbiamo fare tutto a mano?!
Usiamo l'olio di gomiti, che per me è come
l'olio di palma
Ho visto qualcosa che scappava. Vieni qui!
Dicono che se ci
stanno comunque dei grumi di burro non è un problema
perché questi qui si
scioglieranno all'interno del microonde
Però io tutta sta fiducia non gliela
darei, perché c'ho dei grumi di burro grossi "così"
Ogni volta che mi asciugo le mani in
realtà, di colpo sembra qualcos'altro
Il mio bel corpo sinuoso. Ma sta tortiera è minuscola. Questo qui e ci esplode dentro secondo me
I pasticceri per prevenire la crescita eccessiva della torta ci mettono tipo una cosa così
Scusate io qui avevo visto, in questa cucina multi optional
che tra parentesi, è di
mio cugino, quindi ringraziamo
D'ora in poi questa sarà il "Cucino" non la cucina
Prevedo un disastro! (Chef Rico)
Aspetta metto un po' di colla qui
Uelà. Ma lei lo fa così? (Chef Rico)
No
Ma secondo te sono uguali? Proviamolo a mettere dieci minuti in microonde
Come avevo fatto la scorsa
volta ad arrivare al b2
No, no, nonono. Stop!
Noo. nono stop stop!
Sarà quello per...? (Chef Rico)
Si pure per me...Facciamo partire
Così come va. Io me ne lavo le mani
No rigà! E' il microonde? C'è puzza di scoreggia
Ma a tratti c'è quasi un buon odore (Chef Mario)
A tratti?
C'è un odore di m***a
E' cresciuto sto pan di c**o
Cioè a breve arriverà Pierfrancesco e penserà che i nostri c**i hanno fatto faville
Ma sotto com'è un po' umido? (chef Mario)
Mah mi sembra tutto giusto! Non ha uno stuzzicadenti Pierfrancesco
e secondo voi va bene anche una cannuccia dello Stregatto?
Incredibile! (Chef Mario)
Dai è un buon risultato, basta
Siamo così sconvolti quando vengono bene le cose
Caspita! (Chef Mario)
Porca miseria Gu! Hai fatto un lavorone.
Quindi possiamo dire che questa è una ricetta che possono fare tutti? (Chef Rico)
Si
Dieci minuti...al microonde. No troppo spavaldo l'ho detto
devo dirlo in maniera più compita.
Dieci minuti al microonde
No rigà quando sentite odore di c**o si capisce che il pan di spagna è quasi pronto
Più è intenso l'odore più siamo vicini (Chef Rico)
Si. Più è intenso l'odore più siamo vicini alla conclusione
che è un po' come quando vai di corpo
Che è venuto bene
Wow ma questo è enorme! (Chef Rico)
Passiamo quindi agli ingredienti per il
ripieno. Allora avremo bisogno di
philadelphia, burro, zucchero...a velo,
un zitrone e un regalo
Tra parentesi questo qui è un regalo che abbiamo scelto
accuratamente, con dentro un paio di orecchini
Si, non diciamo il prezzo (Chef Rico)
No non diciamo il prezzo
No scherzo, sono i biglietti da visita della ragazza di mio
cugino che sta lavorando a un progetto molto figo
di cui vorrei parlarvi più avanti ma non so se ho il permesso ancora , perché è "top secret"
150 precisi. Pazzesco! Setacciamo 300 grammi di zucchero a velo
lacalacalacalacalaca
Oddio sette anni! Non esiste un modo per...
Noo non c'ho tempo per setaccià, dai su ,ma m'hai visto? Mo settaccio...dai
300 grammi di zucchero a velo non setacciato
150 grammi di burro...525 grammi di philadelphia, con un massimo di tre per cento di grassi
Questo non è uno sponsor ma stiamo cercando di risparmiare un po' di calorie
perchè mangi e booom!
E la scorza di un zitrone
Si. Propongo prima di di mescolare con la
paletta "felice" e poi ci aggiungiamo le fruste
E' già buona
Mettiamo questa qua un attimo in frigo a raffreddarsi
e iniziano a prendere le misure del pan di
spagna
Così al volo con le mani
Passiamo a
questo punto alla parte più difficile
o più divertente o più tragica
cioè ancora devo capire che è quella di infilare questo qui all'interno della torta
Quello che dobbiamo fare per prima cosa è proteggere il regalo
con una pellicola. Bello stretto, chiuso,
ok
Prendete un tagliere sporco, dategli una
pulita. Iniziamo a incidere e iniziamo
a eliminare uno strato. Vedete? Già metà
pacco c'entra dentro
Allora lo piazzate sopra e poi lo tirate fuori cercando di
fargli mantenere la posizione
Sembrava una cosa impossibile, ora vediamo
Ma quando vai a tagliare la torta... (Chef Rico)
No si quando vai a tagliare la torta semplicemente
dira "Ma che cavolo c'è qua è un po' dura"
Beh hai appena tagliato 300 euro di regalo che ti ho fatto
Mazza! (Chef Rico)
Facciamo un pochino di ordine, prendiamo la
saldatrice e incominciamo a chiudere tutto quanto         La prima cosa che dobbiamo fare è quella di
piazzare sui lati la crema, che fungerà
un pochino da collante
Se penso che questi sono i bigliettini da visita di Roberta un pochino rido
non credo che lei farà lo stesso
Chiudiamo
E a questo punto proviamo a fare una cosa che io non so fare ma che mi improvviserò
Chiedo perdono a tutti i pasticceri che mi stanno guardando da casa
se sbaglio qualcosa è perché non ho mai imparato
Beh dai non sono un pasticcere ma cioè, è dignitoso. Poi inventatevi sempre la c*****a che c'avete messo amore
Grazie! Oddio l'amore è l'ingrediente migliore di questa ricetta
nonché il grande assente. La mettiamo un secondo in frigo che si sta sciogliendo. Dai su!
E' arrivato il momento di decorare questo
ammasso di m***a di elefante albino
quindi prendiamo delle fragole e iniziano a
tagliarle
Tiè!
Ma una sciacquata alle fragole? (Chef Mario)
Ah una sciacquata alle fragole prima
Stavo per leccar...ah ma non sono sciacquate
No io il c*****o di nuovo non ce la faccio ragazzi
Son mele cotogne
E' un po' storta però...(Chef Rico)
Eh vabbé. E' storta la casa. Oh ne avanza una Enrico
Stavo pensando di fare questo intanto. Vediamo se ti piace
Questa è da pasticceria (Chef Mario)
No questa è una c****a! (Chef Rico)
No. Sta piangendo pure la torta. Si in cucina bisogna
mandare in caciara, ho capito. faccio uno sui
Faccio una svuirlicchio (?)
Terribile...
Dai su
Ma era più bello se facevi fum fum fum (Chef Rico)
Faccio anche quello. Fum fum fum fum fum. Era più bello si
E questo è il risultato della nostra torta regalo con pan di spagna cotto al microonde
Basta cioccolato Gu! Sisi davero cioè ti prego. Basta! Cioè hai svuotato un barattolo
Vogliamo passare a un micro assaggio?
Aspetta che un po' di fragolina
non ce la mettete dentro?
A te sono stati dati due piedi al posto delle mani. Molto buona. Non è male. Ce sta...Te stai vomitando
Ragazzi questa era la mia torta per San
Valentino. Fatemi sapere se vorrete
cimentarvi in una cosa simile anche se
un po' ve lo sconsiglio
Qualora lo doveste fare
taggatemi su Instagram, fatemi sapere
se questa ricetta in qualche modo vi è
tornato utile
Vi mando un abbraccio, vi invito come sempre a iscrivervi a questo canale e attivare le campanelle
se volete sapere però va beh, se volete essere aggiornati in genera...vabbé le solite cose
che si fanno su Youtube e ci vediamo la
prossima domenica con un'altra ricetta
Ciao ciao